we do have sad news tonight in a
statement the FBI confirmed that two of
the four Americans kidnapped at the U.S
Mexico border last Friday are dead while
the other two are receiving medical
treatment in the U.S and after the news
broke our own peter Ducey press Karine
Jean-Pierre on Biden's very weak border
policy during today's White House Press
briefing and once again she laughably
claimed that the Border safety is a top
priority for this Administration really
I don't think so take a look the
violence aspect of it now Americans are
being slaughtered would president behind
me taking the same approach if it was Al
Qaeda or Isis operating just across the
border from an American city the
president takes this very seriously he
takes this very seriously the FBI and
other agencies have been on top of this
from day one and so that's what he's
going to continue to do when it comes to
Americans lives and when it comes to
their the safety of Americans the
president's always going to make sure
that that is a top priority
now while Biden won't address the crisis
Republican lawmakers are refusing to
stay silent Senator Lindsey Graham
issued this very Stern warning to the
cartels and the Mexican Government last
night take a look
I'm going to introduce legislation Jesse
to make certain Mexican drug cartels
foreign terrorist organizations under
U.S law and set the stage to use
military force if necessary to protect
America from being poisoned by things
coming out of Mexico so what would
Lindsey Graham do I would tell Mexican
government if you don't clean up your
act we're going to clean it up for you
all right so how many times has this
Administration lied to you the American
people lie to all of us telling us the
border is secure here's a quick reminder
to most folks like a crisis well
well at all precisely that the border is
closed nor could I have been clearer and
continue to be so which is the border is
closed the United States will continue
to enforce our laws
order at the border we are working to
make the Border more secure you're
confident this border is secure
we have
border
in that that is a priority for Any
Nation including ours in our
Administration we agree that the border
is secure
here was reaction former White House
aide Stephen Miller and Texas
Congressman chip Roy chip this is this
is right on the Brownsville border what
bothers me is we had in the first two
years of the Biden Administration and
already the month of January this year
we're on Pace to set yet another record
of illegal immigrants Crossing into this
country illegally
um and add to that fentanyl heroin
methamphetamine cocaine human
trafficking uh how do they say with a
straight face that they are on top of
this issue and that our border is secure
because it clearly is not and if they
want to tell that to the families of of
the four people kidnapped two families
that lost loved ones uh I want I don't I
don't think they'd have the courage to
ever do that
yeah Sean thanks for having me on and
look obviously we're very saddened to
have two Americans lose their lives two
others get injured in Mexico but look a
lot of us have been saying this was
coming we've already seen this kind of
violence I was glad to see Peter Ducey
ask of what what we would do if we had
Al Qaeda and Isis just across the Rio
Grande in Mexico because that's
equivalent of what we have you know I'm
glad to hear Lindsey Graham say that
he's going to introduce a bill to
designate them as terrorist
organizations well kind of Welcome to
the party I did that in the 116th
Congress 117th Congress I'm going to do
it again tomorrow in the 118th Congress
because we should recognize the danger
that they pose to the American people
but you know what as sad as it is today
with the with the tragic loss of these
lives what about the 72 000 dead
Americans from fentanyl poisoning in the
last fiscal year what about the four
families that lost their kids in Hayes
County Texas where I live to fentanyl
poisoning what about the almost 1 000
dead migrants found on Texas ranches or
in the Rio Grande River or the 53 three
who died in a tractor trailer in the
Texas Heat last August where's this
administration's compassion where are
all the churches and the ngos down on
the Rio Grande river with their
compassion patting themselves on the
back for being pro-migrant when all of
those migrants are dying and Americans
are dying enough no more words and
Republicans ought to hold the line on
this we ought to designate them as a
terrorist and we ought to withhold
funding until we get this Administration
to do their job to secure the Border let
me ask if Stephen Miller we had a secure
border we had a policy called the stay
in Mexico policy we built you know
hundreds and hundreds of miles of border
wall we didn't quite get to the to the
end
but we had nothing like this in the
Trump years as a matter of fact we had
the lowest numbers of illegal immigrants
entering the country in those years Joe
Biden to me is aiding and abetting the
law breaking he's allowing it to happen
this we do know how to stop it stop this
and prevent this why is he not doing
that
well first of all it's your point Sean
in 2020 we had a policy of complete and
total removal any illegal immigrant from
any country anywhere in the world that
came across our border illegally they
were apprehended and either sent to
Mexico under remain in Mexico they were
sent to Guatemala or another country
under a safe third agreement or they
were returned to their home country
there was Zero releases of illegal
aliens into our country Joe Biden came
into office he terminated every single
policy I just mentioned and began the
process of resettling illegal immigrants
by the millions into our country he is a
human Smuggler he is a human trafficker
and he is the single best financial
asset the cartels have and now we see
the Bloodshed that he has wrought we see
the suffering that he has wrought we see
the death that he has wrought and this
is all on his hands and the hands of
every single Paul petition in Washington
who supports Joe Biden's policies and
after the election Chuck Schumer said he
wants amnesty for for each and every one
uh chip I'll give you the last word on
this and and that is that I would even
argue that that illegal immigrants are
getting preferential treatment they
didn't have a vaccine mandate in the
middle of a pandemic they didn't even
have a covet check we had kids in cages
the media that railed against Donald
Trump didn't say a word uh then we have
the Biden phone issue and free
transportation to any one of the 48
states in the continental U.S that's
that's aiding abetting assisting if I
did it would I get arrested you're a
lawmaker
yeah no question look what we've got now
is encounter and release is the official
policy of the United States because of
Joe Biden and as a result Americans are
dying and migrants are dying we could
solve it tomorrow I have legislation H.R
29 which would simply say you know what
once you've got somebody here you've got
to detain them to adjudicate an asylum
claim or you got to turn them away same
Powers we've been using under title 42
the return to Mexico micro protection
policies but you've got Democrats
completely against it almost every
Republican supports it but there's a few
who are kind of hemming and hawing and
ringing their hands the American people
demanded that we do something about this
we should use the power of the purse to
force the change to secure the border of
the United States last quick question
different topic chip will all 222
Republican house members unite on a plan
uh on the debt ceiling that they agree
on uh or will they you know will they
separate because I think the Democrats
have calculated politically that the
Republicans won't unite do you believe
they will
yeah well as you know you and I have
been talking about this we're working on
it hard uh look getting 218 220 on that
is difficult but look keep it simple
let's just return spending to
pre-coveted levels get us on a path to
balance and let's break the whoa the
woke weaponized federal government that
is going after the American people we
can do that if we Unite by the way that
would work for most Americans and
conservatives and be true to the
promises Republicans made hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else